- (laughing) You're always on the go.
So, are you one of those people
that you don't have to sleep much?
- Naw, I'm about four hours, five hours.
- [Kelly] What?
- Yeah.
(audience exclaiming)
- Oh my god.
I'm a demon if I don't get eight.
(audience laughing)
(50 Cent laughing)
I can survive on like six, seven,
but eight is a solid.
- I tried.
I'm up.
So I started to do a little meditation.
Do a little meditation, so I-
- I wish I could that.
- I get my mantra from Deepak Chopra.
- [Kelly] Wow!
- I'm not good at it.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] I'm not either.
- But I try it.
- They tell you to not think of things,
and all I think about not thinking.
- It's hard not to think.
- Yeah.
- Yo, I'm saying (reciting mantra),
saying the mantra.
Then, I'm all the way over there.
I gotta figure out how to do this.
And then I'm right here,
and them I'm somewhere else in thought.
You're supposed to not think.
You're supposed to relax
and just calm yourself down but-
- [Kelly] I can't do it either.